look at this fact check from AP News
zelenski didn't say here's what AP says
zelenski didn't say U.S troops needed to
fight in Ukraine that's weird that's
actually what he did say he did say that
so here's here's the framing they're
going with
claim a video clip shows Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski saying that
Americans want to send their sons and
daughters to the war in Ukraine
ap's assessment missing context zelenski
was explaining that if Russia attacked
NATO member states which are U.S allies
the U.S would likely send troops to
protect those countries he was not
suggesting Americans would have to fight
in Ukraine right because it's going to
be in Poland that the U.S troops are in
Poland and they'll never go into Ukraine
there will be no advancement on that
front once the U.S pushes Russia out of
Poland and then Russia is occupying
Ukraine the US of course would be like
we are done supporting this war Ukraine
is lost of course because because that's
what he certainly meant